bonsoir à tous deux invités ce soir dans
ce spécial preuve par trois entre deux
tours des élections législatives d'abord
des films bateau bonsoir ministre
délégué à la justice ce qui a triomphé
dès le premier tour dans les deux sèvres
dans l'ex circonscription de ségolène
royal et puis ensuite philippe marini le
président ump de la commission des
finances on l'attend sur la question des
déficits publics mais aussi du front
national à propos duquel il est plutôt
décomplexé avec moi ce soir sujet de
blocs de l' agence france-presse notre
partenaire et perrine tarneaud de public
sénat et vous bien sûr les
téléspectateurs par le biais de
l'application tivi tchèque d'orange
delphine batho d'abord ségolène royal
donc on le sait est en grand danger pour
cause deux duels fratricides à la
rochelle et puis il y a eu cet
incroyable rebondissement ce tweet qui
tue de valérie trierweiler est ce que
vous demandez comme jean louis bianco de
quoi elle se mêle valérie trierweiler
est une femme indépendante donc sa
parole n'est pas celle d'une responsable
politique elle n'engage ni le président
de la république ni le gouvernement ni
le parti socialiste a émis une opinion
personnelle qui n'est ni la mienne ni
celle du gouvernement
je crois qu'on ne peut pas dire comme
vous venez de le faire qu'il y à une
sorte de duel fratricide à la rochelle
parce qu'on pouvait dire qu'il y avait
aucune compétition au premier tour entre
la candidate de la majorité
présidentielle légitime ségolène royal
est un dissident
olivier falorni mais ce duel a été
arbitrée par les électeurs de gauche au
premier tour est ségolène royal qui l'a
emporté qui est en tête du premier tour
et qu'il est donc en situation de
devenir la députée de la rochelle et
donc cela me permet de dire que la
candidature d'olivier falorni a changé
de nature entre le premier et le second
taux à 2 il est devenu le candidat
soutenu par la droite soutenus par
dominique bussereau et ségolène royal
est la cause majeure la compagnie du
président de la république
en plus de mal à comprendre la position
de valérie trieweiler un appel je
voulais dit elle n'est pas une
responsable politique c'est un appel de
ma part aucun commentaire ce n'est pas
une responsable politique mais elle vit
quand même avec le président de la
république françois hollande qui est
intervenue pour soutenir franchement
s'exprimer clairement pour soutenir
ségolène royal comme comme nous tous
d'ailleurs
et vous savez ce qui compte parce que
les rochelais sont des citoyens libres
ils vont pas voter en fonction d'un
tweet ils vont fonction vous voter en
fonction des projets en fonction de la
qualité des personnalités du bilan qui
est celui de ségolène royal et je pense
que ce qu'ils font comprendre étant élus
de la région je peux vous le dire c'est
qu'il y as dernière la façon dont
aujourd'hui olivier falorni est devenu
le candidat soutenu par la droite une
volonté de dominique bussereau qui a été
sèchement battu par ségolène royal aux
élections régionales ségolène royal qui
avait aussi battu jean pierre raffarin
en 2004 il ya une volonté de la droite
d'essayer de battre la présidente de la
région poitou charentes en cette
élection législative royal de rockstore
franchement franchement est-ce que c'est
au niveau de la qualité du débat
politique que les citoyens attendent moi
je ne crois pas en campagne du président
intervient dans un des points les plus
chauds
licht relative peut pas dire que c'est
un hold up ça n'appelle pas de
commentaires je vous ai dit c'est une
femme libre indépendante elle a le droit
d'avoir ses opinions personnelles mais
ça n'engage pas ni le président de la
république ni le gouvernement ni le
premier ministre ni le parti c'est la
franchit les limites de la neutralité
selon vous oui forcément habitiez projet
partie sur ses pas de commentaires à
faire je vous ai dit c'est une femme
indépendante
voilà il faut pas gérons pas passer
l'émission sera bien sûr bon beaucoup de
responsables socialistes sont accablés
c'est votre cas aussi non moi je suis
engagé pleinement derrière ségolène
royal je pense qu'elle va gagner je
pense qu'elle va gagner je pense que
ségolène royal est une dingue grande
dame de la vie politique française
si je suis là aujourd'hui devant vous
c'est aussi parce que c'est quelqu'un
qui a toujours donné sa chance aux
nouvelles générations
mais ça
sur wii c'est qu'elle invite à laisser
sa circonscription de louis elle m'a
donné cette chance en 2007 de faire mes
preuves par moi même et d'être
maintenant élu au premier tour
et ça c'est quelque chose d'important
vous pouvez en témoigner des films à
tourner ce qu elle même ne sait pas
donner les meilleures chances pour
atterrir à la rochelle elle a refusé une
primaire socialiste nom acide au
parachutage finalement non non elle
n'est pas parfait dans sa propre région
vous pouvez pas dire que ségolène royal
est parachuté elle a été investie par le
parti socialiste avec notre soutien à
tous dans une circonscription il y avait
déjà une difficulté on le savait entre
le maire de la rochelle le député
sortant maxime bono et olivier falorni
qui n'a rien voulu entendre
c'est dommage pour lui et c'est dommage
pour celui qui était un militant
socialiste de n'avoir aucun embarras à
être aujourd'hui soutenu par la droite
dans la façon dont il l'est mais vous
dites qu'elle va gagner mais il a
envisagé se défaite aujourd'hui en
disant qu'elle ne quittera pas la
politique de toute façon parce que c'est
une combattante ségolène royal donc
c'est normal a répondu à une question
qui lui était posée mais moi oui je
crois je pense qu'elle va gagner parce
que tout le monde dans notre région
connaît l'extraordinaire travail qu'elle
a fait pour l'excellence
environnementale pour les petites et
moyennes entreprises pour les jeunes
apprentis et cette capacité de travail
elle est prête aujourd'hui à la mettre
au service de la rochelle et de la
république aussi dans des fonctions
parlementaires alors tant ils avaient si
elle n'est pas élue députée dimanche je
vous la voyez ou à la tête du parti
socialiste par exemple il sera toujours
un
elle sera présidente de région et qu'on
travaille comme présidente de région
mais je veux qu'elle soit élue dimanche
prochain alors bon vous êtes prudent
dans vos commentaires sur le ce fameux
tweet de valérie trierweiler parlons
peut-être de la prise de position
officielle de françois hollande
puisqu'il a rédigé un mot pour la
profession de foi de ségolène royal il
est donc intervenu alors qu'il avait dit
qu'il n'interviendrait plus comme
président dans les affaires du parti
socialiste hélas en contradiction avec
lui-même non c'est l'exception qui
confirme la règle et il ya une exception
pourquoi pas ce qu'il y a la façon dont
un candidat a voulu semer une confusion
qui n'a pas lieu
d'être et on sait aussi que ségolène
royal a joué un rôle important dans la
campagne présidentielle notamment dans
l'entre-deux-tours dans
l'entre-deux-tours aussi des primaires
et donc c'est ça sociale
ce cas le cas du vaucluse où il y à la
candidate socialiste qui se maintient
malgré les consignes du parti socialiste
se retirer pour laisser la place à nu et
désistement rigoler c'est qui cette
situation tout de même différente
emma situations c'est quelqu'un qui se
présente comme un comme un comme un
dissident et qui veut battre une
candidate légitime de la gauche avec les
voix de la droite
vous savez normalement la règle à gauche
c'est que c'est au premier tour qu'on
arbitre d'éventuels conflits internes à
la gauche est donc là on est sorti du
cadre c'est ce qui c'est ce qui motive
aussi l'engagement du président de la
république
si marine le pen est élue dimanche
prochain à hénin beaumont
est ce que jean lui que je ne souhaite
pas est ce que jean luc mélenchon en
portera une part de responsabilité tant
il a placé la présidente du front
national sous le feu des projecteurs
pendant cette campagne coûtait rien
n'est joué
moi je souhaite que philippe kemel gagne
dimanche
et pour cela il faut que tout ce qu'on
votait jean luc mélenchon au premier
tour votent pour le candidat socialiste
au second tour et donc nous ne
commençons pas à tirer des bilans avant
que le deuxième tour des élections
législatives soient joués vous savez que
largement mélenchon lui même tirs des
bilans il est amer aujourd'hui ya
seulement 36 ans consommation dans
laquelle dans lesquelles il n'y aura pas
de second tour dimanche prochain
donc ça veut dire que dans la majeure
partie des circonscriptions de france il
y à un second tour et donc ne faisons
pas les analyses politiques les bilans
qu'il faudra faire en temps utile avant
que le second tour soit joué
alors voilà pourtant nous sommes dans
une bataille et dans une bataille
notamment pour battre marine le pen à
propos du front de gauche et des
communistes on prête à françois hollande
eu l'intention de les faire entrer dans
le gouvernement il y aura un remaniement
bien sûr peut-être qu'avec votre
victoire du premier tour vous serez
promis je ne sais pas déjà un promotion
en venait d'arriver
ce qu'il faut faire rentrer des
covalente au gouvernement après le
second tour des législatives ne peux pas
t'en sors c'est une prérogative du
président de la république et du premier
ministre qui examineront cette question
certainement après le second tour moi
j'en ai soit 6 mai que ce serait fondée
je n'ai pas de à intervenir dans la
composition du gouvernement les tic moi
ce que ce serait une bonne chose et je
vous ai répondu je n'ai pas à interférer
dans ce qu'ils sont des prérogatives
vous savez le nouveau gouvernement un
esprit d'équipé
un esprit collégial mais nous voulons
aussi incarner une forme de remise en
ordre des institutions et donc chacun
doit être dans ses prérogatives les
prérogatives du ministre et même des
ministres délégués n'est pas de dire ce
que sera la position du premier ministre
et du président de la république sur la
composent d'ordres ouvert mais est ce
que en tant que député socialiste
aujourd'hui ministres au gouvernement
suit plus d'effort vous avez été réélu
mais vous êtes mise
vous siégez pas pour l'instant est ce
que vous êtes inquiète pour l'instant il
n'y a aucun cumul
oui entre des fonctions parlementaires
et des fonctions ministérielles savoir
23 de la constitution a fait tout à fait
vous avez été élu vous serez sans doute
à nouveau siéger à nouveau après vos
fonctions ministérielles mais ce que
vous êtes inquiète aujourd'hui de la
situation des alliés traditionnels du
parti socialiste le front de gauche mais
aussi les écologistes qui peut-être
n'auront pas de groupe à l'assemblée
nationale écoutez on verra sur la base
du résultat des élections nous nous
souhaitons une majorité forte cohérence
solide
oui un widget eux dans la mesure du
possible plutôt que si une majorité
diverses avec toutes les composantes de
la gauche un seul ce serait encore mieux
écouter plus il y aura deux invités
socialiste lui il y aura des réalités et
de gauche dimanche prochain
mieux nous nous porterons pourquoi parce
que c'est une condition pour pouvoir
mettre en oeuvre le programme
présidentiel sur lequel françois
hollande a été élu si on veut que la
réforme fiscale soit votée que la loi de
programmation pour l'école soit votée
que la réforme bancaire soit votée il
faut une majorité de gauche justice a
voté également bienvenu donatien
vous êtes proche de ségolène royal vous
l'avez
appelez vous défendez l'ordre juste vous
incarnez la sécurité j'ai envie de dire
un discours un peu musclé est ce que
vous êtes totalement à l'aise dans la
composition à la chancellerie qui vous
fait cohabiter avec créé christiane
taubira qui a été dépeinte par l'ump
comme le symbole du laxisme
alors non seulement je ne courais vite
pas avec christiane taubira mais c'est
une femme que j'admire énormément avec
qui nous allons faire un excellent
travail et même j'espère je crois que
nous allons faire un tandem d'enfer elle
est garde des sceaux
moi je suis ministre délégué auprès
d'elle pour veiller sur un certain
nombre de prérogatives précise qui
concerne les droits des victimes
l'exécution des peines la promotion des
droits donc c'est tout le problème de
l'efficacité de la justice le fait que
les décisions de justice souhaite
effectivement suivis d'effets qu'elle
soit appliquée c'est ça le travail que
je vais effectuer avec christiane
taubira oui mais je veux insister c'est
ce que je vous disais à l'instant sur
l'esprit d'équipé c'est vrai que dans le
précédent gouvernement avec nicolas
sarkozy on voyait les ministres se
chamailler entre eux c'est pas du tout
ce qui se passe dans l'équipe de jean
marc ayrault
il ya un beau mais c'est notre volonté
cette collégialité cette solidarité et
ce travail en équipe
le premier texte qui vient finir ou
parlement sera celui sur la nouvelle loi
sur le harcèlement sexuel
il avait vous de travailler c'est
christiane taubira et najat vallaud
belkacem qui ont travaillé sur ce texte
qui était très attendu puisqu'il ya eu
cette décision du conseil
constitutionnel qui aboutit à une
situation de vide juridique qui est
insupportable pour les victimes de
harcèlement sexuel est donc moi dans les
prérogatives qui sont les miennes
ce que je veux dire c'est que le travail
du gouvernement et du parlement puisque
le projet de loi va ensuite à discuter
sur un plan parlementaire qui vise à
aboutir au vote d'une loi le plus
rapidement possible est indispensable
pour que dès le mois de septembre à
l'automne prochain une personne une
femme qui est victime de harcèlement
sexuel sur son lieu de travail puisse
aller porter plainte
et puis obtenir la condamnation de ces
comportements vous savez
un des problèmes qu'il ya sur le
harcèlement sexuel comme sur les
agressions sexuelles dans leur ensemble
c'est que de très nombreuses femmes ne
portent pas plainte
et moi je veux que les victimes aient
confiance dans les années 80
condamnation je crois par an c'est très
par rapport à la quantité de témoignages
que l'on reçoit que l'on connaît de ce
qui se passe il faut pas généraliser
justement vous êtes en charge du droit
des victimes
la défense de la défense des victimes et
des droits des victimes
donc comment avez vous participé dans ce
texte puisque c'est un volet essentiel
là on peut voir justement votre travail
d'équipé avec madame taubira peut-être
en pratique
vous dites que c'est elle qui a siégé de
travail encore ce soir il ya d'ailleurs
une réunion qu'elle pilote avec najat
vallaud belkacem avec les associations
et puisqu'il ya un certain nombre de
remarques qui ont été faites
c'est une usine à gaz avec ou non il ya
la volonté du général nation et c'est
pas simple mais non il ya la volonté du
bon vraiment d'assurer la sécurité
juridique puisque c'est ce qui a été
reproché par le conseil constitutionnel
d'assurer la sécurité juridique de ce
dispositif mais d'abord il ya un
dialogue qui se poursuit et un texte qui
est déposée il ya le parlement qui va
faire aussi un travail très important
que ce soit au sénat où déjà des
sénateurs opposition de l'oise hanoi
absolument évidemment il ya un débat
parlementaire vous savez je parlais de
la collégialité
cela vaut aussi pour le respect du
parlement qui doit être associée
pleinement aux réformes et ce sera c'est
ce qu'a indiqué à plusieurs reprises
jean marc ayrault qui est lui même un
peu un qui a été pendant tant d'années
un parlementaire chevronné leurs yeux on
peut lire dans paris match cette semaine
que nicolas sarkozy va bénéficier de la
protection de dix policiers pour un coût
annuel estimé à 700 milles euros est ce
que c'est normal où vous l'avez appris
avant cette émission moi j'ai aucun
commentaire à faire j'imagine que si
c'est le cas c'est qu'un risque a été
mesurée sont manifestement à une deux
qu'ils étaient satisfaits de l'ancien
président de la république ça vous
paraît beaucoup consacrée aux dix
policiers pas d'informations et de
commentaires
que pensez vous de la part d'un deal
père de mohamed merah contre l'aso qui a
conduit à la mort de son fils
terroristes meurtriers comme on le sait
il avait annoncé cette démarche l'avait
choqué lorsqu'il l'avait fait d'autres
sentiments
mon sentiment c'est que je crois pour
connaître le travail des policiers qui
est un travail tellement difficile celui
des policiers du raid
mon sentiment c'est de leur faire
confiance mais si cela c'est la justice
est saisie elle se elle se prononcera
également bien sûr est ce que vous
seriez allé au chevet du jeune de
villiers-le-bel qui a été renversé le
week-end dernier lors d'une collision
avec une voiture de police le ministre
de l'intérieur s'est rendu aux hommes
oui bien je suis solidaire du ministère
derrière vous comprenez sa démarche
évidemment très bien la justice
est-ce que vous pensez que le nombre de
fonctionnaires du ministère de la
justice doit être remonté de combien il
a écouté l'engagement qui a été pris par
le président de la république c'est que
au cours de son quinquennat 1000 postes
seront créés dans la police la justice
et la gendarmerie
donc il y aura prochainement un travail
sur le budget pour l'année 2013 qui sera
même un travail pluriannuel avec la loi
de programmation des finances publiques
qui permettra de dire la ventilation de
ces mille postes entre la police la
gendarmerie et la justice mais
évidemment on le sait que l'institution
judiciaire
vous savez moi mon sentiment c'est que
de la même façon que le gouvernement
nouveau en arrivant trouve une situation
de déficit public très lourd de la même
façon que dans le domaine de l'éducation
nationale on trouve un système scolaire
qui a été profondément mis en difficulté
par la suppression d'un certain nombre
de postes
nous trouvons un passif dans
l'institution judiciaire avec un manque
de moyens avec une institution qui a été
malmené dont l'indépendance a été mise
en cause avec beaucoup de peine qui ne
sont pas exécutées
et avec des magistrats des personnels
des greffiers aussi auquel il faut
redonner du courage du respect de
l'écouté et c'est ce que nous faisons
avec christiane taubira qui mène un
travail remarquable et notre volonté
c'est d'abord de travail et d'écouté et
ensuite de communiquer de grandes
priorités après la loi sur le
harcèlement sexuel qu'ils seront les
prochains textes concernant la justice
vous savez justement la justice n'est
pas que changer les lois
pendant dix ans nous avons eu une
accumulation de loi à chaque fois qu'il
y avait un crime grave
il y avait une loi supplémentaire donc
nous nous voulons te faire un travail
sérieux
un travail en profondeur conduire un
certain nombre de réformes en écoutant
ce qu'on attire aussi les personnels de
l'institution judiciaire et donc nous ne
ferons pas dans cette logique
d'accumulation des lois nos fronts des
lois utile justement avec notre avec
notre partenaire orange et l'application
tvcheck qu'on a une question qui nous
arrive de giovannoni qui vous demande si
en matière de justice les premières
mesures du quinquennat de françois
hollande vont servir à détricoter la
politique menée ces dernières venaient
par nicolas sarkozy il faudra revenir
sur un certain nombre de mesures par
exemple qui sont inefficaces
je parle et on a parlé des tribunaux
correctionnels pour mineurs la forme qui
sont soit stoppée soit écornée
écoutez l'engagement du président de la
république que nous avons pris devant
les français pendant la campagne
électorale c'est une justice plus
accessible plus efficace
il ya eu une accumulation de textes
comme je vous le disais donc le
parlement sera amené à faire un travail
pour évaluer ce qui marche et ne marche
pas et ce qu'il faut ce qu'il faut
supprimer
allez vous étiez là d'abord pour parler
des législatives c'est bien cela
delphine batho alors au ni ni de l'ump
et répond l'a évoqué tout à l'heure avec
siècle le front républicain du parti
socialiste met donc dans le seul cas où
il pourrait être appliqué face à marion
le pen dans le vaucluse la candidate
socialiste refuse de se retirer alors là
vous dimanche un cas pratique dimanche
prochain vous voteriez pour l'ump dans
cette circonscription
il faut battre le front national c'est
ce que l'artiste socialiste a donné
comme consigne dans cette
circonscription ce dommage que ce ne
soit pas
suivi mais je voudrais quand même
insisté sur une chose je voudrais quand
même insisté sur le jeu dimanche là il
ya 480 circonscription dans lesquelles
le débat sera entre la gauche et la
droite
il ya soixante et une circonscription
dans laquelle le front national est
présent
en 1997 il y avait cent trente trois
circonscriptions dans lesquels le front
national est présent donc je ne veux pas
que le débat de centre de cet entre deux
tours soit complètement monopolisé
cristallisé par cette question qu'est-ce
qui est sérieuse que je ne nie pas du
front national alors que la grande
question de dimanche prochain
c est ce qu on donne une majorité au
parlement à françois hollande
ou est ce qu ont rétabli les amis de
nicolas sarkozy dans une forme de
situation de cohabitation de désordres
qu'a priori non vous êtes en ballottage
favorable
vous le savez il faut encore que le vote
soit amplifiée dimanche prochain parce
que notre pays traverse une crise
économique une crise sociale et qu'il
faut que le gouvernement et la
légitimité du parlement pourra
généralement sur le front national quand
même
nadine morano qui évoque les valeurs
communes avec le fn et qui donne une
interview à minute ça vous fait réagir
bien sûr on avait déjà vu ça dans
l'entre-deux-tours de la campagne
présidentielle
donc c'est toujours la même stratégie
qui continuait ce qui est regrettable
pour l'ump c'est que cette stratégie de
légitimer de légitimisation de l'extrême
droite qui a conduit nicolas sarkozy à
sa défaite parce que c'est un élément de
sa défaite se poursuivre aujourd'hui
merci beaucoup delphine batho on va
parler du front national justement
maintenant avec eux philippe marini le
président ump de la commission des
finances est sénateur de l'oise où
l'extrême droite a décroché trois
triangulaire dimanche prochain on voit
d'abord l'ondé de choc à l'ump entre la
règle édictée donc par le bureau
politique et puis la tentation d'accord
du côté des électeurs et de certains
élus locaux alors comment s'y retrouver
jérôme ravier confrontés à des
triangulaires et un électorat de plus en
plus favorables à des alliances locales
avec le front national l'ump devait
trancher
réunis en bureau politique d'hier le
parti a approuvé in yeux clairs pour son
secrétaire général
dans tous les cas de figure nous
n'appelons pas à voter pour le front
national
naturellement nous n'appelons pas non
plus à voter pour un candidat socialiste
qui a choisi de s'allier pour gagner
avec l'extrême gauche ni front
républicain ni alliance avec le fn tout
le monde semble a priori sur la même
ligne du moins jusqu'à dimanche prochain
et les réfractaires ont été priés de se
taire il a donc été recommandé de se
taire là dessus et de laisser le parti
ou alors on fait pas partie du bureau
politique les l'humaniste de l'ump qui
affiche d'habitude sa préférence pour le
ps en cas de duel avec le fn est
clairement visé pourtant dès aujourd'hui
certains élus n'hésitent pas à critiquer
cette stratégie c'est une solution que
je comprends mais je ne partage pas je
pense que c'est une solution qui était
une solution de court terme c'est à dire
que ça permettra peut-être de remporter
à la marge quelques circonscriptions
supplémentaires mais je crains que sur
le long terme cette solution aboutisse à
une certaine forme de banalisation de
l'extrême droite qui finalement ne sera
pas favorable d'autres élus n'ont
pourtant pas ses réticences à l'image de
nadine morano en difficulté en meurthe
et moselle qui a clairement appelé les
lecteurs du front national a voté pour
elle l'ancien ministre de la défense
gérard longuet défend lui aussi un
dialogue avec les électeurs du parti
frontiste
c'est un acteur de la vie politique
française à part entière c'est un acteur
pelé comme le front de gauche comme le
parti socialiste est un acteur politique
mais ça il n'y a pas marqué pestiféré
d'ici dimanche et le second tour des
législatives l'ump restera sur cette
ligne politique
c'est seulement ensuite lors de la
bataille qui s'annonce pour prendre la
tête du parti que les langues pourront
vraiment se délier au sein de l'ump
voilà philippe marini le président ump
de la commission des finances nous a
rejoint bonsoir et merci d'être avec
nous donc avec toujours suzette bloch et
perrine tarneaud alors quelle est votre
position à vous face au front national
vous avez entendu notamment votre
collègue monsieur lecerf qui dit ce
ni-ni entraîne un risque de banalisation
de l'extrême droite
moi je constate que le front national
fait sensiblement moins qu'à la
présidentielle très et demi pour cent
sur le plan national
cd score auquel on est habitué depuis 25
ans alors il ya des plus y'a des moins
mais il faut franchement pas faut pas en
faire un fromage de la position de
fromage la position de l'ump a changé
moi je dis c'est mon analyse personnelle
que l'enjeu de cette élection
législative c'est le nombre de députés
socialistes je considère et qu'il serait
très dommageable à la république que le
parti socialiste et la majorité absolue
à lui d'en est tous liés à lui tout seul
donc chaque siège est important et moi
il y adeux d'éliminer ceux ci avait
résolument il y a deux députés
socialistes et à mon avis mieux notre
pays sera gérée et plus on se remettra
rapidement les pieds sur terre
monsieur chassaing qui s'est retiré dans
le vaucluse nouvelle il lui appartient
d'apprécier l'état d'esprit de ses
électeurs et le climat de sa
circonscription
je suis un décentralisateur et
je ne mets pas en doute sa bonne foi il
s'abonne s'est retiré il appelle à faire
barrage à michel vauzelle qui est aussi
le président de la région paca
vous faites le même appel que lui moi je
ne fais aucun appel
je n'en ai vu que sa position non mais
je dis simplement que s'il y a quelques
députés en ont très limitée du front
national la république va pas être
transformés et que à l'inversé le parti
socialiste a vraiment tous les pouvoirs
dans cette république y compris le
pouvoir constituant nous serions alors
danger donc vous estimez que le front
national peut être un contre-pouvoir
utile mais je n'ai mais ne faites pas
dire des choses qu'on écoute et non mais
vous ne me faites pas dire des choses
que je n'ai pas dit ce qu'on a compris
j'estime que l'enjeu c'est qu'il y ait
dimanche prochain le moins possible de
députés socialistes au que par exemple
l'élection de marine le pen serait
légitime de les aider à tirer toutes les
conclusions que vous voudrez je vous ai
dit ce que j'ai dit oui bon on a compris
que ça a été trouvé légitime qu'il y ait
effectivement il gauche deux députés
font de ces assemblées nationales à
moins de rire un peu le ps elle doit
être représentatifs des courants d'idées
est pensée comme l'a dit très justement
gérard longuet les électeurs en question
qui ont été très nombreux aux
présidentielles un peu moins aux
législatives au premier tour ne sont pas
des pestiférés ne vous êtes d'accord
avec jean à l'ong israël je suis
totalement d'accord avec géré alors oui
ça lui donne une interview minutes ont
écouté écoutez je pense que que
s'agissant d'un hebdomadaire
c'est clos d'ici dimanche prochain dont
au demeurant sur les sujets de ma
compétence
je n'ai jamais refusé d'interview à
personne sur cette stratégie du ni ni de
l'ump certains quand même au sein de
votre parti estime que c'est une
position à court terme
c'est par exemple le cas de bruno le
maire ou d'autres sénateurs
ici elle sert aussi par exemple mais
nous sommes un rassemblement très large
il y à différentes façons de réagir et
même de penser dans notre mouvement
j'estime que son unité doit être réservé
à tous c'est à dire non mais j'estime
qu'il est parfaitement légitime que dans
l'ump
il y ait différentes sensibilités qui
s'expriment
vous avez bien compris que le jeu du
front national c'est d'attirer une
partie de ses sensibilités qui qui qui
lui sont proches ajouté que l'on
sincèrement l'ump est à 35 % le front
national est attrait et demi le rapport
de force
y'a pas photo est ce que une partie de
l'ump n'a pas déjà fusionné dans sa tête
avec le front national comme le dit
arnaud montebourg
écoutez tout ça ce sont des des
vaticinations médiatique et et quant aux
alors comment s'appelle le ministère
d'arnaud montebourg et semant production
redressement réductive alors il veut
redresser les entreprises
oui ce qui me semble passer les esprits
à redresser les esprits je lui laisse
ces tendances que je trouve
alors oui mes amis les marines et qu'est
ce qui a changé depuis les cantonales de
2001 alors hein on s'en souvient alain
juppé françois fillon ou nathalie
kosciusko morizet défendent elles feront
république a plus aujourd'hui qu'est ce
qui s'est passé eh bien vous m'aviez
interrogées à ce moment là je vous
aurais dit je ne choisis pas d'accord
mais vous vous étiez en quelque sorte un
préfet nommé écoutez moi j'ai ma liberté
et j'aime l'ump je suis heureux de
représenter l'ump d' exercer une
responsabilité pour l'ump parce que
c'est un groupe libre où on peut
s'exprimer acteurs d'ailleurs dans
l'avenir nous aurons des tendances qui
seront
organisé et il y aura un congrès ou en
toute transparence les idées vont
s'exprimer et les organes dirigeants
seront tes le comme on doit le faire
dans un parti démocratique
à partir de liste de programmes et
documents d'orientation et ça aurait
toujours dû être comme ça alors pourquoi
tu as des alliances locales côté et je
vous ai dit ce que je vous ai dit
socialiste et mieux se portera la
république d'accord donc alors bienvenue
à quelques députés front national pour
faire pièce à leur niveau c'est ce qu'on
comprend de vos propos encore une fois
que des marines une dernière question
sur le sujet diriez vous comme dan
indigne morano que vous avez vous
partager des valeurs communes avec le
front national côte est le premier à
avoir dit ça c'était vers 1986 était
charles pasqua ah oui et vous savez que
j'ai gardé beaucoup de tendresse charles
pasqua allez vous avez livré aujourd'hui
même
philippe marini une charge contre les
projets de françois hollande
est-ce que la situation d'après vos
informations et avant même que soient
connus l'audit de la cour des comptes
est ce que la situation est plus urgente
que jamais pour les finances publiques
oui bien sûr quels sont vos informations
les finances publiques sont dans un état
critique et nous avons le devoir de
renforcer de défendre la crédibilité de
la zone euro nous ne pouvons le faire
qu'en affichant et en respectant une
discipline total tient pas revenir à 3%
de déficit public à la fin de 2013
on y arrivera c'est pas moi c'est pierre
moscovici qui a dit très récemment le
nouveau ministre est que pour l'année
2012 nous dérivantes nous sommes des as
déjà dans une tendance vers 5 à 5,2 pour
cent alors que 4,5 était prévu donc un
correctif sera indispensable
je voudrais simplement qu'on nous dise
pour combien quand d'accord entre elles
qui fera les sacrifices combien d'impôts
supplémentaires combien dépense en moi
j'ai aussi demandé un délai
supplémentaire à nos partenaires
européens
on peut reporter un petit bout et les
chats et bien jean
mais ceux qui se sont appliqués la
rigueur et la discipline nos amis
allemands sur qui tout repose je veux
dire l'allemagne elle a fait les efforts
elle s'est restructuré lcl à changer de
comportement ça a été douloureux
elle a pas envie de payer pour les
autres et on les comprend
et si on était à leur place on tiendrait
une position très ferme
alors pierre moscovici le ministre des
finances lui dit on peut arriver à cet
équilibre sans mesures d'austérité ce
qui les crédits quand c'est une question
de mots il va falloir prendre des
mesures pour améliorer le solde
améliorer le solde sans austérité
dutil cela veut dire soit augmenter les
recettes soit diminuer les dépenses et
faire une combinaison entre les deux
c'est inévitable alors maintenant si
l'augmentation des impôts vous êtes pour
mais je dis que les condamnés
l'orientation qui parle de matraque à
l'augmentation des recettes des
prélèvements et une est une nécessité
accord mais la diminution des dép en
hausse également elles nécessité et
c'est une affaire de proportion moi j'ai
simplement repris vous savez et j'ai
diffusé un document de travail très
détaillé ce matin c'est transparent tout
le monde peut le consulter il est
maintenant sur internet
j'ai repris les chiffres qui sont dans
les engagements de françois hollande qui
sont dans les documents du parti
socialiste avec le programme de
stabilité que nous avons approuvé au
mois d'avril c'est à dire la projection
triennal et c'est très proche des
chiffres de françois hollande dont j'en
déduis qu'avec le ralentissement de la
croissance avec la difficulté à tenir la
norme de la dépense publique
il va falloir prendre des mesures
supplémentaires 10 milliards
d'ajustement en 2012 et 20 milliards en
alors avec ou sans austérité ça ça
dépend du gouvernement
mais si l'on veut parvenir à 3% le
déficit public afin de
13 ce qui est la condition de notre
notation du code nos empreintes
crédibilité il va bien falloir trouver
cet argent
françois hollande vient de dire que la
croissance ne naîtra pas de dépenses
publiques supplémentaires s'est rassuré
écoutez ça me parait ça me paraît assez
évident mais en même temps il avait
laissé entendre qu on rechercherait le
salut de l'europe avec des dépenses
européennes supplémentaires et des
projets bourse pour financer des
investissements d'infrastructures j'ai
regardé quels montants 4 à 10 milliards
pour les 27 pays de l'union européenne
est ce que vous croyez que ce sont des
chiffres et qui sont significatifs pour
la croissance française c'est peanuts on
peut les cas il défend toujours ses
investissements européens en art et or
il n'a pas de jeu l'approuvent
mais laissez pas de ça que notre
croissance va venir et est ce que vous
voyez quand même une inflexion heureuse
pour vous dans son discours
effectivement quand devant le conseil
économique et social et environnemental
le chef de l'état et dit que la
croissance ne naîtra pas de dépenses
publiques supplémentaires
heureuse lucidité heureuse lucidité mais
maintenant si j'étais un électeur de
gauche
ce que je ne suis pas j'aurais entendu
tout un discours pendant des mois et des
années
et puis au moment où arriverait les
actes de gouvernement
peut-être que je ne me retrouverais plus
parce que l'ajustement de 10 milliards
qu'il va falloir faire avant la fin de
l'année 2012
pour moi c'est le même montant que le
plan fillon de septembre 2011
mais vous l'encouragez bien sûr dans
cette voie et bien entendu parce que
soit on reste dans l'euro soit on en
sort et on dit pourquoi faire et pour
rester dans l'euro il faut être crédible
on défend notre rating est sérieux et
par conséquent aboutir à nos engagements
respecter nos engagements vis-à-vis de
nos partenaires et vis-à-vis de ceux qui
nous prêtent de malheur vous saluer
l'heureuse lucidité du chef de l'état et
en même temps vous dites ça va être la
gueule de bois pour les électeurs de
gauche je dis simplement que l'on
veuille bien
aller au bout de la transparence ont
fait voter nos concitoyens dimanche
prochain sans leur dire la vérité à
temps dans l'eau doute elle est bien
bonne
l'audit a bon dos nous avons reçu la
cour des comptes il y a deux semaines
qui a dressé l'état au 31 décembre 2011
ce qu'elle nous dira au titre de 2012 ça
donnerait un peu de chance d'être
différent et nous avons par ailleurs les
observations de la commission européenne
qui sont parvenus le 31 mai sur le
programme de stabilité que le précédent
gouvernement a adressé au mois d'avril
du coup nous avons toutes les
informations du coup pour avoir cette
transparence à ce que vous allez
convoqué très rapidement après le
deuxième tour des législatives
les ministres des finances et du budget
devant votre commission ici au sénat
pour avoir des éléments sur la future
politique du gouvernement
bien entendu cela va de soi et c'est
déjà prévu le 20 juin la semaine
prochaine nous allons élire un nouveau
rapporteur général
on nous dit ce serait mon excellent
collègue du finistère en soit mark bon
nous allons naturellement travailler en
binôme puisque la commission des
finances est une commission dont kate
majorité petite majorité mais une
majorité que je respecte
elle a un rapporteur général un
président nous avons une seule et même
équipe de collaborateurs
donc même si nous pensons différemment
salon travailler ensemble comme j'ai eu
le plaisir de travailler avec nicole
bricq du collectif budgétaire qui n'est
heureusement pas rien du tout je ne sais
pas quels sont les contours du collectif
je ne sais pas comment la matière
fiscale en particulier va être partagé
entre le collectif et la loi de finances
pour 2013 dont les arbitrages montée de
fait au cours de l'été et qui sera
adopté par le conseil des ministres mois
de septembre il ya beaucoup de questions
qui se posent dans tous les domaines
fiscaux fiscalité des entreprises
fiscalité de l'épargné fiscalité des
personnes fiscalité du patrimoine
qu'est ce qui va être dans le collectif
qu'est ce qui va être dans la loi de
finances mais cela n'avait reçu aucun
document
non aucun document ce normal écouter les
nouvelles autorités sont là depuis peu
de temps mais moi je n'en souffre pas
particulièrement j'ai une très grande
patience mais je me mets à la place des
électrices et des électeurs qui vont se
prononcer dimanche prochain et je pense
qu'ils auraient le droit de savoir très
bien au delà des quelques indications
assez vagues qui ont été donnés il
aurait le droit de savoir ce qu'on va
faire et avec quelles conséquences
votre homologue de l'assemblée nationale
sera bientôt de votre couleur politique
les paris nice que vous avez une
préférence pour écouter tout le monde
sait que j'ai eu un très très grand
plaisir à travailler comme rapporteur
général pendant de très nombreuses
années avec gilles carez donc moi
naturellement mon voeu c'est que nous
poursuivions ensemble beaucoup d'autres
prétendants valérie pécresse
voilà françois baroin voilà le candidat
et donc écoutez moi je ne veux pas je ne
sais pas député donc c'est le vote ce
sera le vote du groupe ump de
l'assemblée nationale
moi mon voeu est il est très clair c'est
de poursuivre l'excellent travail en
commun que j'ai fait pendant tant
d'années avec gilles carez parce que
c'est un garçon qui est indépendant qui
dit ce qu'il pense
ici pas le cas non mais écoutez
non non non gilles carez est quelqu'un
qui travaille beaucoup qui fouillent les
choses et qu'il est qui ne parle d'eux
un surhomme il n'est pas une conviction
fondée par le menu la bonne
fréquentation des anciens milka et côté
d'or icaunais écoutez écoutez donc
j'avais enfin les rites et presque
vraiment bon alain brion extraordinaire
décidée mais dans ce rôle je préfère
gilles carez ceci dit c'est pas moi qui
vote et fryma e re travailler avec le
président qui sera là alors il ya une
question qui nous arrive de notre
partenaire orange avec l'application
tvcheck la gauche pourrait voter est ce
que la gauche pourrait voter vos
propositions de taxation des géants du
web
alors j'ai observé sur ce sujet une
assez nette convergence dans les
analyses qui ont été faites par nicolas
sarkozy par françois hollande lui-même
par sa spécialiste du sujet devenu
secrétaire d'état fleur pellerin
mon but dans ce domaine c'est de
travailler à une prise de conscience de
la situation inadmissible inéquitable
dans laquelle se trouvent les over the
top et très grande entreprise
multinationale d'origine américaine qui
utilisent opportunément et toutes les
ressources de la fiscalité et du droit
pour se localiser en irlande au
luxembourg aux îles caïmans ou ailleurs
il faudrait contrôler tout ça qu'est ce
que vous dites
il faudrait surtout que l'on me dernis
notre fiscalité
parce que si l'on voit échapper de la
fiscalité les assiettes les plus
modernes est celle qui progresse le plus
qui va payer
ce sont les autres etc l'inéquité la
plus apte au talent et ça pourrait
rapporter combien ça écoutez l'enjeu sur
les années qui viennent est un enjeu en
milliards d'euros
deux petites questions en rapport avec
le parti socialiste le premier ministre
jean-marc ayrault déclare que l'ump
prépare une alliance stratégique avec le
front national que lui répondez-vous
mais mais mais mais c'est une cc cc
c'est une vue de son esprit ccc c'est
évidemment écoutez comment voulez vous
que l'on puisse imaginer une chose
pareille
bon maintenant je
je voudrais savoir s'il ya des électeurs
de voter ouvrière de lutte ouvrière qui
votent pour un candidat socialiste
est ce qu'il ya un accord stratégique
entre lutte ouvrière est le parti
socialiste même avec le front de gauche
est ce que sur tous les sujets il y à un
accord stratégique et en particulier sur
ceux dont nous venons de parler c'est à
dire la nécessité d'être sur les 3% à la
fin de l'année 2013
qu'est ce que le parti comme pour les
liners gül le premier ministre
nous sommes dans une semaine
préélectorale chacun fait ce qu'il peut
avec ses mots bien entendu mais là je
pense que le que le premier ministre est
vraiment très très loin de toute réalité
crédible père et nous a occupés à la
rochelle opération il faut sauver le
soldat royal branle bas de combat
françois hollande est intervenu
aujourd'hui martine aubry étaient sur
place et puis patatras en milieu de
journée un tweet de valérie trierweiler
la compagne de françois hollande est
tombée elle soutient le camp l'autre
candidat socialiste dissident face à
ségolène royal
mais moi je pense que les affaires de
famille où les liens personnels non pas
à jouer de rôle en politique on a trop
reprocher souvent à juste titre à
nicolas sarkozy d'être trop influencée
par sa fille personnel et par sa vie de
couple pour accepter cela d'une autre
manière et dans d'autres circonstances
je respecte beaucoup
la personnalité de madame trierweiler
que je trouve élégante séduisante qui
est une femme libre et quel sens de ses
responsabilités mais pour autant elle
n'est pas mandaté elle n'est pas élu
pour prendre une position de cette
nature surtout quand on peut imaginer
qu'elle serait peut-être motivé par un
tout petit peu de ce sentiment si
compréhensible de jalousie la jalousie
j'allais vous interrogez c'est la
jalousie qui est derrière tout ça je
n'en sais rien moi je ne lis potez et
crédible pour vous je ne saurais sondés
c'est le coeur et je ne connais pas le
sujet mais mais c'est ce et c'est à cela
que ressemble cette déclaration merci
merci et c'est regrettable
merci à vous philippe marini d'être venu
ce soir dans preuve par trois merci
bonsoir à tout ça très vite
en 2005 samsonite fabricant américain de
bagages ferme son unique site français à
hénin beaumont dans le pas de calais le
sinn reprise par un constructeur de
panneaux solaires dépose le bilan 18
mois plus tard les salariés licenciés
sans indemnités dénonce une machination
juridico-financière pas un seul panneau
solaire qui a été fabriquée sur le site
reina bull baas donc c'était des
panneaux solaires pas été apportée
d'allemagne pour faire croire au
personnel que on pourrait en faire
l'essai tu parles liquidation totale ou
la longue bataille judiciaire de
salariés contre un géant industriel
un documentaire d'hélène desplanques
samedi à 22h sur public sénat suivi d'un
débat animé par élise lucet
chaque année 70 mille personnes sont
hospitalisées sans leur consentement
alors que la loi qui encadre ces
hospitalisations vient d'être réformé la
réalisatrice lorène debaisieux a enquêté
sur le monde de la psychiatrie
j'avais envie de parler d'un sujet qui
me semble encore très tabou
je pense que la folie fait peur encore
aujourd'hui et que j'avais envie de
parler des fractures de la société s'en
fait partie et je pense que c'est une
manière de décrire la société que de
raconter comment la société traite c'est
fou c'est un an jean durroux dans des
prisons aussi c'est une façon de voir
quel est le niveau d'une société
exactement pas rare de voir comment elle
gère à la marge les personnes ne sont
pas dans le circuit de pala l'automation
et dérivés liberté c'est un enjeu
important parce que il ya à peu près 70
mille personnes qui sont hospitalisées
sous contrainte par an et que ça
correspond à peu près au nombre de
personnes qui sont incarcérés équivalent
donc c'est vrai que c'est comparable
l'enjeu est important et voilà nous
semblait important de donner la parole
aux personnes concernées parce qu'à ce
qui est dur dans l'histoire mais vous
êtes la mère d'un enfant comme ça qu'on
demande à hospitaliser c'est quoi c'est
la trahison qu'on semble lui faire c'est
la peur de se tromper c'est quoi là je
n'avais pas peur de me tromper toute
façon je suis pas tout seul dans le gag
c'est une mère ne veut pas hospitaliser
son enfant de force il n'ya pas l'avis
du psychiatre
donc il ya des médecins qui vous appuyez
ou chivu non qu'ils disent oui mais il
n'ya pas que vous vous vous le demander
mais bon ce qui est c'est vous voyez
votre enfant partir dans une ambulance
en ayant une piqûre calmantes de force
dans la fesse voilà il vous suivez vous
arrivez en pleine nuit dans un hôpital
psychiatrique que ce soit sainte anne ou
poly guiraud d'autres c'est quand même
un peu style asile du 19e siècle
donc voilà ma fille me disait qu'il m'a
fait interner chez les fous non je t'ai
fait hospitaliser parce que tu es malade
et a besoin d'être là reprochés
boozer fois c'est terrible pour pour
avoir la conscience après récupérer elle
peut elle comprend pas elle veut pas et
puis petit à petit petit à petit il ya
quand même une espèce de compréhension
que ça n'est pas vraiment pour lui faire
du mal et que l y trouve aussi elle a
fait la démarche est elle même parfois
d'y aller seul vous en même temps
aujourd'hui elle était en bonne hausse
paix des nations libres a quand même si
c'est ça je choisi d'y aller
we dance et une évolution dans son
entraînement et dans son état oui il
serait donc admis qu'au fil du temps que
vous l'ayez fait le bon choix que
d'appeler des médecins pour la
contraindre à se faire soigner
oui c'est ça oui en gros c'est ça oui
concrètement comment ça se passe quand
on rentre comme ça hospitalisé à la
demande d'un tiers ou d'office dans un
hôpital
on n'est pas libre on est enfermé on est
contrat on est attaché on en famille ou
dans une chambre et quoi on est avant
tout protéger c'est le mot mais
concrètement la vérité c'est quoi pour
protéger ma vérité des faits mais dans
toute la médecine il ya des mesures qui
sont prises quand on reçoit quelqu'un
qui est à moitié dans le coma au bape on
va on va prendre toutes les dispositions
pour qu'ils ne se fassent pas de mal en
tombant
nous nous devons faire en sorte que
puisqu'il n'est pas conscient des
troubles dont il souffre qu' il ne part
qu'ils ne quittent pas l'hôpital
immédiatement qu'il ne ne se fasse pas
du mal qu'il ne fasse pas de mal à
d'autres patients enfin c'est toutes ces
mesures devraient en outre leur
incarcération mais on est on est qu'à
dans une logique de privation de
contraintes
on peut on le prenait un traitement à
quelqu'un qu'il refuse on peut le faire
sans tous les usages 1 et toutes les
règles on peut le voir sous ce regard là
mais non mais c'est là pas assez
critique
mais c'est une protection nécessaire et
qui n'est pas discutable puisque
l'arrivée du juge c'est c'est très très
difficile à vivre pour les ti cats qui
jusqu'à présent était un peu maîtres
chez eux et qui sont maintenant obligés
effectivement de justifier encore une
fois la privation de liberté nous avons
eu de longs débats à l'assemblée pour
savoir si le juge devait aussi
intervenir dans l'obligation de soins il
nous est apparu nous députés toutes
tendances politiques confondues
l'obligation de soin à domicile à
l'extérieur extérieur à quelques
nouveautés de la loi aussi un
dépendamment d'obliger déçoit mais là il
n'ya pas le regard des juges pour
l'instant indépendamment voilà de la
privation de liberté il nous a semblé
que le juge n'avait pas à intervenir sur
l'obligation de soin ça c'est le rôle du
médecin ce rôle du psychiatre
à côté de ça la notion de privation de
liberté elle est fondamentale et ça ce
n'est pas du ressort du médecin c'est
vraiment du ressort du juge de la
liberté
savoir si je suis plus calme aux
patients et à mesure on pas de sortir
alors ça se passe plus ou moins bien
selon que les juges se déplace à
l'hôpital ou pas nous avons aujourd'hui
dans les auditions que nous avons mené
le premier bilan montre qu environ 30%
des juges se déplace dans les hôpitaux
et dans ce cas là ça se passe
globalement très bien est ce qu'ils
comprennent bien vous êtes de leur côté
par en face et comment ça se passe qui
sont vraiment s qui revendique ses
tresses est très variable à dire qu'il
ya les tout une certain nombre de
patients qu'ils comprennent pourquoi ils
sont là et toute une autre partie qui
n'est pas d'accord d'ailleurs il ya eu
hospitalisations sans consentement c'est
bien qu'au départ le patient n'était pas
n'était pas consentante mais au bout de
15 jours parce que nous nous intervenons
quand même quasiment au bout de 15 jours
et va pas pas toujours pas toujours pas
toujours mais en tout cas
alors pourquoi je vois quand même un
certain nombre de personnes qui
n'étaient pas d'accord pour être
hospitalisés qui dit jour twitter haber
adhère mais vous en libérer en premier
mais combien alors peu près 5 à 6% 5 à
6%
demagny évaluations en primaire
enfin stressé par an compétitif l'école
est elle en panne
ils ont débattent sur le plateau d'
élise lucet
j'ai trois enfants donc deux plus grands
19 et 16 ans et un plus petit qui a 6
ans et j'ai été très frappée parce que
donc les trois on n'a pas changé de
quartier on est resté dans la même école
et à dix ans d'intervalle je n'ai pas
reconnu la maternelle